AS IF CONGRESS DOESN'T HAVE
ENOUGH ON ITS PLATE, NOT THAT
IS DOING ANYTHING WITH WHAT IS
THERE, THEY ARE NOW LOOKING
INTO UFOS.
AT LEAST THEY ARE DOING
SOMETHING, RIGHT?
CONGRESS IS EXPECTING A REPORT,
NEXT MONTH, FROM THE DIRECTOR
OF NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE, AND
OTHER AGENCIES, ON UFOS OR,
UAPS.
THAT IS THE GOVERNMENT TURN FOR
THEM.
IT SAYS 4 UNIDENTIFIED AERIAL
PHENOMENA.
WHY?
A RETIRED U.S. NAVY PILOT,
COMING FORWARD TO SAY, HE AND
HIS CLUE WITNESSED AN
UNIDENTIFIED FLYING OBJECT ON
THE COAST OF THE ATLANTIC,
SEVERAL TIMES.
AND, HE IS NOT THE ONLY ONE.
JOINING US NOW, SOMEONE WHO HAS
PERSONALLY WITNESS SIGHTINGS,
RETIRED NAVY CHIEF, MASTER AT
ARMS, SHAWN CAHILL.
JOINED BY CHRISTOPHER MELLON,
FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE FOR
INTELLIGENCE.
THANK YOU BOTH, APPRECIATE YOUR
JOINING ME.
>> GOOD EVENING CHRIS.
>> PLEASURE.
>> SO, LET'S DISPENSE WITH THE
OBVIOUS HERE.
CHRIS, PEOPLE WILL I ROLL AND
SAY, WHAT IS CUOMO HAVING TO
TALK ABOUT TONIGHT.
WHY IS THIS WORTH DISCUSSION?
>> BECAUSE WE HAVE RECURRING
VIOLATIONS OF U.S. AEROSPACE,
BY UNIDENTIFIED OF VEHICLES,
THEY ARE VERY CAPABLE IN SOME
CASES MORE CAPABLE THAN
ANYTHING IN OUR OWN INVENTORY.
THIS IS BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS,
AND THE TRUTH IS JUST EMERGING.
WE'VE HAD A MASSIVE
INTELLIGENCE FAILURE, WE NOW
HAVE A THREAT, AN UNKNOWN
THREAT THAT WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT.
>> SO SEAN, IT'S NOTHING
WORRIED ABOUT SOMETHING OUT OF
A MOVIE COMING TO GET YOU, IT'S
ABOUT THE THREAT RIGHT HERE ON
EARTH AND HOW IT'S BEING
MOTIVATED WITHOUT OUR KNOWLEDGE
AND ABILITY TO COUNTER?
>> THAT'S CORRECT, CHRIS, IN
2004 AS THE CHIEF MASTER ON
BOARD THE USS PRINCETON, THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE REALIZE IS
SOMETHING WE WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO DEFEND OUR FORCES AGAINST
THE.
TIME >> HELP ME UNDERSTAND,
THAT WHAT DOES THAT MEAN TO US?
>> WHAT WE UNDERSTAND AS THE 5
OBSERVABLE, INDICATE A
TECHNOLOGY THAT OUTSTRIPS OUR
TECHNOLOGY BY AT LEAST 102,000
YEARS AT THE MOMENT.
>> 102,000 --
MEANING WHAT'S KIND OF
TECHNOLOGY WAS A PLAYER ABLE TO
IDENTIFY BUT NOBODY CAN MATCH
IT.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THE AIRCRAFT
HAD ZERO CONTROL SURFACES.
IT HAD NO MEANS OF PROPULSION
THAT WE CAN DETECT, IT MOVED AT
HYPERSONIC VELOCITY'S AND IT
PROCEEDED THE PILOTS TO THEIR
CAP POINT.
IT SEEMED TO HAVE SOME
KNOWLEDGE OF WHERE THE PILOTS
WERE HEADED AHEAD OF TIME, WE
DON'T POSSESS THOSE ABILITIES
TO DO THAT IN OUR ARSENAL AT
THE MOMENT.
>> WHAT DOES THAT SOUND LIKE TO
YOU?
>> WELL, WE CLEARLY ARE
VULNERABLE AND THIS IS BEEN
GOING ON FOR TOO LONG, FINALLY
OUR CONGRESS IS LEARNING OF THE
SITUATION AND BEGINNING TO
REACT.
SO WE'VE GOT A LOT OF CATCH UP
HERE, BUT IT IS VERY CONCERNING,
IT'S NOT A CRISIS, AN IMMINENT
THREAT, THERE'S NO HOSTILITY.
THERE'S A LOT OF ACTIVITY
INCREASINGLY BOLD AS SOME
INCENTIVES WE RECENTLY HAD
AROUND WARSHIPS OFF THE COAST
OF CALIFORNIA, SWARMING AROUND
STRATEGIC MISSILE DEFENSE BASES
IN GUAM AND OTHER.
THANKS --
WITH CHINA AND THE REST WITH
THE ATTACK ON THE SAUDI OIL
FACILITIES BY DRONES, IS
SOMETHING WE NEED TO TAKE
SERIOUSLY.
>> YOU ANSWER THE QUESTION
PARTLY THERE, BUT LET'S FILL IT
OUT A LITTLE BIT.
THIS IS NOT NEW, PEOPLE PLAY
WITH THIS AND THEY PLAYED ALL
KINDS OF CONSPIRATORIAL
THINKING, BUT A LOT OF REAL
MILITARY POLICY PEOPLE SAY LOOK,
THERE ARE THINGS OUT THERE THAT
WE'VE GOT TO KEEP TRACK OF.
THAT WE CAN'T, BUT WHY NOW?
WHAT'S NEW IN TERMS OF THE
URGENCY, CHRIS, I'LL ASK YOU
BOTH ABOUT THIS.
>> SURE, HOW DO YOU ADDRESS.
THAT WOULD HAPPEN WAS A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO THE PENTAGON WAS
MANAGING THIS ACTIVITY WITH
ALMOST NO RESOURCES.
I AM A FEW OTHERS BECAME AWARE
THIS WAS GOING ON ON A VERY
SIGNIFICANT SCALE, IN THE EAST
COAST AT THE TIME WHEN OUR
PILOTS ARE NOT GETTING ANY
SUPPORT.
THE INTEL COMMUNITY WAS NOT
RESPONDING, NOBODY WAS HELPING
THESE GUYS OUT, IT WASN'T BEING
REPORTED AT THE CHAIN.
IT WAS UNTIL THAT GOT INTO THE
NEW YORK TIMES, GOT TO THE
ATTENTION OF CONGRESS THAT
FINALLY OUR LEADERSHIP IN BOTH
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT BECAME
AWARE THIS IS GOING ON.
SO THIS IS ONLY JUST COME TO
LIGHT.
>> SHANNON, WHAT DO YOU THINK
IS THE LIKELY UNIVERSE OF
EXPLANATION THAT WILL COME UP
AT THE END OF THESE REPORTS AND
ADDRESSING OF THIS?
>> CHRIS, I THINK YOU ARE GOING
TO FIND THAT THIS PHENOMENON
REPRESENTS A VERY LARGE
SPECTRUM OF DIFFERENT THINGS.
EDGES OF THAT SPECTRUM ARE
GOING TO BE NEAR PIERRE
TECHNOLOGY OF OUR ADVERSARIES,
HERE ON EARTH.
THE OTHER END OF THAT SPECTRUM
IS GONNA BE SOMETHING THAT WE
DON'T YET UNDERSTAND AND
HAVEN'T IDENTIFIED YET.
SO, I HESITATE SPECULATE ON THE
SOURCE BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT
IT DON'T BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
WITHIN OUR ARSENAL, OR ANY
HUMAN TECHNOLOGY AT THE MOMENT.
>> SO, WHEN YOU SAY THAT ALMOST
GUARANTEE IS THAT NOT JUST ARE
GOOD LOOKS, BUT THAT STATEMENT
WILL GET THIS PICKED UP AND
SENT UP ALL OVER THE INTERNET,
BECAUSE THEY'LL BE A LEGIT
MILITARY PERSON SAYING THAT
MAYBE THIS IS FROM OUTER SPACE?
DO YOU WANT THAT TO BE TAKEN
FROM PEOPLE?
>> WELL, THAT WOULD BE TAKING
MY WORDS OUT OF CONTEXT.
WHAT WE CAN SAY THAT WE DON'T
KNOW WITH THIS, IT'S HERE.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE ALL OF US TO
FIGURE THIS OUT TOGETHER.
>> AND CHRIS, WHAT'S YOUR
COMMENT ON THAT?
LOOK AT THE RESUMES OF THESE 2
GUYS, PEOPLE SAY THAT THEY'RE
BOTH SAYING THAT IT MIGHT BE
FROM ANOTHER WORLD?
>> THERE IS NO SCIENTIFIC
REASON OR BASIS TO DOUBT THAT
POSSIBILITY, IT'S A HYPOTHESIS
THAT COULD EXPLAIN THE FACT.
PEOPLE NEED TO BE OPEN TO THAT,
WE'RE SPENDING BILLIONS LOOKING
FOR EXTRA TESTS THRILL
SITUATIONS, IT'S POSSIBLE
SOMEBODY FOUND US BEFORE WE
FOUND THEM.
>> AND THE AGE OLD QUESTION
THAT I'VE BEEN WATCHING MOVIES
MY ENTIRE LIFE, IF THEY'RE
SMART ENOUGH TO COME HERE AND
HAVE SUCH ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES
WHY DON'T THEY TALK TO US?
>> WELL, IF THEY ARE THAT SMART
WITH I HAVE TO LEARN FROM US?
YOU GO TO THE ZOO, DO YOU TALK
TO THE ANIMALS?
>> I GOTTA TELL YOU SHAWN,
WE'RE NOT PRESENTING AS EXACTLY
THE BEST KIND OF PEOPLE, WE ARE
EATING OURSELVES DOWN HERE
RIGHT NOW.
I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY THEY WANT
TO KEEP AN ARMS REACH.
>> YEAH SEAN, LAST WORD TO YOU.
>> I WAS JUST GONNA SAY, IF
THERE IS SMART AS WE THINK
THERE THEN I THINK WE'RE KIND
OF SILLY THINKING THAT WE CAN
GET THEIR MOTIVES.
>> AND FOR ME, THERE IS NO THEM,
I AM A FACTS FIRST KIND OF GUY
ON THIS.
I'M OPEN TO EVERYTHING, THERE'S
SO MUCH I LEARNED LIFE THAT I
WOULD'VE NEVER EVEN IMAGINED
BUT I DO KNOW THIS, I WORRY
ABOUT THE SAFETY OF MEN AND
WOMEN LIKE YOU SHAWN AND CHRIS,
IF YOU WILL WIN OF HEAVEN
ACROSS THE POLICY LINE TO GET
INTO PRACTICE.
I WORRY THAT YOU'RE SAFE, I
WORRY THAT PEOPLE AREN'T
BEATING US AT OUR OWN GAME,
THAT WE HAVE TO LEARN THROUGH
BLOOD AND TREASURE THAT WAS
UNNECESSARY.
ANY EXPIRATION, ANY RESEARCH,
ANY REPORT, ANY HEARING THAT
HELPS US UNDERSTAND HOW TO KEEP
FIGHTING MEN AND WOMEN SAFE IS
THE ONLY WAY TO HONOR YOUR
SACRIFICE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT,
THANK YOU FOR HAVING A
CONVERSATION, CHRIS, SHAWN, AS
YOU LEARN THINGS OR YOU LEARN
OR YOU DON